what's up guys
and welcome to today's video in this one
we're going to be revisiting the kicking
fundamental series that there were a
couple of episodes of before
the first one was about the arc of
attack relating to the angle at which a
kick comes across a target and retracts
and the second was about pivoting on the
feet and how to correctly align the hips
in order to kick correctly
this one is going to be about how to
generate momentum and velocity into your
kicks to make them nice and explosive
and powerful
now all these fundamentals work together
in a kind of synergy
in order to deliver the best outcome but
at the same time is that they're not me
trying to tell you like this is the only
way you can do it and don't try any
other methods
i think anyone who tries to put any kind
of like heavy dogma on you and say that
like there's only one way to do
something and it's their way
you should be quite wary of so i think a
good coach basically like points in the
direction of something and lets somebody
kind of try it out and figure their own
way out to do it
what i'm basically trying to do with
these videos is kind of like
point some things out to people and
hopefully maybe highlight some blind
spots or areas they've missed in their
own training
so that they can improve their own
technique and get better now just before
we get into it further head over to my
own personal channel at youtube.com
grantstevensma i'm now uploading regular
content on there and i've just put up a
tornado kick tutorial a really in-depth
guide
including some exercises to improve that
so head over there like and subscribe
and all that good stuff as well
so the first thing to start with as
always is to make sure that you've not
got any huge holes
or big areas that you're kind of missing
within your own kicking technique
already so if you head over to
the other video that i did last time
which was five exercises to improve your
kicks
that should really help you as a good
starting point before you build on it
and the thing that we're going to be
focusing upon today
is the really early stage at which a
kick is initiated
so above all things if you really
practice these motions going into your
kicks
the rest of what happens pretty much
takes care of itself and the velocity at
which you're able to deliver a kick
directly relates to this initial stage
so to think of it this way you almost
want the kicks to be effortless or at
least
feel that way and in my experience the
kind of thing that knocks off most
people is if they've got something wrong
in the initial stage
then it really knocks the rest of the
move off and they end up spending kind
of all of their energy
and the rest of the move kind of
catching up and course correcting this
video is going to be quite similar in
nature to the kinetic linking video i
did about punching power before
obviously though with kicks for this one
and the main thing that we're going to
focus on is how the arms are used to
generate momentum
in conjunction with the movement of the
feet going into and then delivering a
kick and some
exercises you can do in order to
implement those principles to improve
your own kicking technique so the
different kicks that we're going to look
at are a spinning kick motion
which in this case is a spin back kick
and a regular turning kick i chose only
two kicks for the purposes of this video
as it can get a little bit overwhelming
and confusing to talk about
similar motions again and again the area
of interest that we'll be focusing on
here are the early or initiation stages
of the kick
and in these two kicks is these
positions here between these
now in order to gain some reference
material for this we're going to look at
this study of
taekwondo kicks and the relation of the
movement of the pelvis
and how that affected the power and
deliverance of a kick so this makes a
lot of sense in terms of me saying that
the kick should kind of just happen and
be effortless
if the first parts are done right with
the peak pelvis velocity happening early
and then the foot velocity happening
later
so the pelvis is something you have more
control over the movement of with it
being a part of the core whereas the
foot
is on the end of a limb with less
control now this next part is really
interesting and it basically talks about
how some of the subjects had a much more
powerful sidekick than others and it was
determined that it was due to a faster
kicking leg action and lower body
movements but what made it work so well
was actually the synchronization between
those two elements
so they're both important on their own
but when done in sync it had a much more
dramatic effect
[Music]
so let's take a look at the way i'm
going into this spin back kick then now
as i initiate the move the first thing
that really happens is this motion with
my hands
now everyone always thinks of this arm
when they're talking about spinning
kicks because it's the most obvious one
that you see
first and it's like you bring it across
into a kind of pseudo hook
punch kind of position which is really
important however the real
one that creates the actual power is
this back one which is often overlooked
you'll see what i mean in a moment so
you see the arm at the minute just kind
of looks normal
and then watch as i start to actually
really create the force and speed with
it how much it kind of flexes
from where it was now you can see how
tense is here
and this is because i'm really using it
to pull my body around so it goes kind
of from
this regular position to a really
forceful flex position to create this
torque which is
the speed at which an object rotates
around its axis so my axis being the
core here
this is going to create torque and then
bring this kick right through to the bag
now i keep pulling this one across at
the same time this one comes up
and goes into that hook punch position
which is important i said but not as
important
i pull this one right back this
continues to pull me round
and the coral stays as one unit my
shoulders all are kind of straight and
my arms are in line
because if i started to twist out of
alignment if this went too far back or
this one stayed behind
it's gonna twist the body and take away
from the power so as i keep pulling this
round
this one is still guiding me here and
i'm almost bringing up and bringing my
elbow forward to continue that momentum
this is also the point where the leg has
begun to lift to actually kick as well
and at the same time as this this foot
is starting to rotate through
in order to get into that position now
bring this elbow right back here i'm
still guiding it forwards as i'm doing
the kick and
another thing to mention here which is
super important is as
i do go into the kick this one my left
arm
begins to lift upwards like this
and that creates that twisted position
in order to
get the power so this is actually kind
of holding my body into this position
because if i
didn't have it here and it was more
through here i would my body would be
more twisted this way
and i would not be as unbalanced and
able to really stack that momentum from
this leg
and deliver that powerful kick into
there so you can see
even as i push into the bag here how
much my body is twisting up it even
continues even more so
and i'm holding this one here as well to
balance on the other side
it's like my body's almost flat and then
it twists into this position
here and so all of these things work
together but really the power
comes from that spin and then this point
where the body kind of twists against
each other and it said in that study as
well that when the subjects were
executing a sidekick it was the twisting
of the pelvis as well as the kicking
motion synchronized
that made the power
[Music]
[Music]
this begins from the arms and i'm
lifting up this right one here this one
is coming back already
to get myself into position and it's
basically the synchronization of all of
these parts together now this one i'm
going to almost whip it down
and bring it behind me as this hip comes
forwards and turns over so i can strike
the bag somewhere around here
so as you see this one is pulling me
back again
and this one at the same time as the
hips coming forward is almost going
against the hip
and as i actually extend the kick it
keeps moving forwards and creates almost
again that counterbalance in motion to
where i'm able to
really twist and my body is staying on
the side but's position because if i was
not
using this counterbalancing motion my
other hands here up as well balancing me
if this hand wasn't here my body would
twist more this way
and my head would twist that way in the
same direction as the legs so
the reason i do these things is
obviously to create that power to really
push that hip forward
and also to counterbalance me as i do
the kick so i don't fall off balance now
in slow motion this can look really
strange and it looks like i'm kind of on
my tiptoes as i kick there
but when you're sitting fast like this
you can see how it all happens as one
motion and it's not as exaggerated but
just for the purposes
of this video and breaking it down i'm
showing you it like this
now let's just go back very quickly and
see how all of this works together
at the same time as the foot begins to
pivot so can you see here
i've already pretty much got my hip 80
percent of the
the way they're into position and when
people struggle with this
it's when they haven't got their hip
into that position
and they try to force it last minute so
they're actually kind of having to catch
up with themselves and course correct as
they go through
rather than getting in position early
and letting the kick just happen
as we mentioned earlier a simple way to
get used to the feeling of this is just
to pretty much try
getting yourself into that pre-kicking
position as fast as possible so you can
see i'm doing that here and just going
through the motions of the technique by
emphasizing the speed of initiation
going into it so you get used to
generating that momentum before the kick
so i hope you enjoyed this video guys
and found it useful let me know in the
comments if you've got any questions or
anything like that
head over to my channel at youtube.com
grantstevenzma and subscribe
and thanks very much and i will see you
next time
you